today we tell you about the first woman
drafted in the nba
lucia harris aka the queen of basketball
the first african-american woman
inducted in the nae smith basketball
hall of fame was one of 11 children and
hailed from the magnolia state
mississippi
as a child her love of the game came
from staying up late so she could watch
nba legends like wilt chamberlain kareem
abdul-jabbar and oscar robertson she
walked the halls at amanda elsie high
school standing six foot three inches
and was given the nickname long and tall
and that's all they would later find out
that she was much more than just tight
harris dropped a school record 46 points
led the school to a state tournament and
took her talents to delta state
university despite the obstacles the
queen never let up on the court in four
years she led the lady statesman to
three titles in the association for
intercollegiate athletics for women she
finished her collegiate career as the
most dominant women's player of her era
averaging 25.9 points and 14.5 rebounds
per game in the summer of 1976 she was
selected to the usa women's team to
participate in the first women's
basketball tournament in the olympic
games they faced japan in their first
games
harris would put her name in history
books forever by scoring the first ever
points in the women's olympic basketball
tournament and leading them to a silver
medal the late pat summitt said she was
like shaquille o'neal so strong and
physical but great hands and great touch
around the basket
a dominant center the following year the
nba came calling as the new orleans jazz
selected harris in the seventh round of
the 1977 draft and would later invite
her to tryouts she felt it was a
publicity stunt and declined the offer
harris who was pregnant at the time had
shifted her focus to her family and
coaching she never once regretted the
decision if i was a man there would have
been options for me to go further and
play
i would have had money would have been
able to do a lot of things that i wanted
to do
yeah they're millionaires famous but i
wanted to grow up and shoot that ball
just like they would shoot it and i did
her legacy is cemented for eternity
lucia harris the queen of basketball a
pioneer a trailblazer
[Music]
this is only the beginning